- Goals.
- Set your goals.
- Setting goals.
- Set goals.
- Set little goals.
- Goal setting.
- Set some goals.
- Set goals.
- Goals.
- Hello Believe Nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe and
I believe that entrepreneurs
will solve all of the
worlds' major problems.
So, to help you on your journey
today we're going to learn
how you can set goals.
If you're watching and you
hear something that really
resonates with you, please
leave it down in the comments
below, put quotes around it,
you might win a prize, but
also, when you write it
down, it's much more likely
to stay with yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(uplifting music)
- I got an older white male,
he's probably in his 60's
maybe, and my man says to me,
"I heard what you said ET,
but how do you sustain it?"
I'm like, "okay, all right
say it again because I want
to make sure I'm hearing
what you're saying".
He's like, "you talk about
going 120, you talk about going
hard, you talk about having
what you want, being what you
want, do what you want, okay
I get it, but how do you
sustain it?"
I'm thinking is that a real question?
I said, "listen to me very
closely, how did I start
this whole presentation off?"
He said, "write down the
people's name that you love."
I said, "duh, if you're waking
up every day and thinking
about your wife, duh, how
do you not sustain it?"
If you wake up every day and
you're looking at your son,
how do you not sustain it?
You think I'm going to put
my kid's life in the hands
of some other man?
You think that's my role as a father?
You think my role is to
allow my kids to come here,
and pay all this money to go
to school, and do everything
they did and now they've got
to go beg somebody else for a job?
That's not my role or responsibility.
Sustain it?
What do you mean?
How do you not sustain it?
I asked you, "why are you not pumped up?"
Why you have days off?
I'm asking you why you give 70%.
You don't love nobody?
Is there not somebody
that you don't love more
than yourself?
Is there not somebody
that you're waking up for?
Is there not somebody you're grinding for?
Somebody told me that
they get distracted easy.
Let me tell you something,
the reason why you're
getting distracted easy is
because you don't got eight
or nine things you wake
up to every single day
and say, "I've got to go get that".
Many of you are getting
distracted because you don't
have something that's
stronger than the distraction.
You need something stronger
than the distraction.
You're getting distracted with parties.
You're getting distracted with smoking.
You're getting distracted with drinking.
You're getting distracted with sleeping.
You're getting distracted
with video games.
Why?
Because the video game is
stronger than your goal.
I tell my homies all the
time, bro, if it don't have
anything to do with, you all be playing.
I'm like, if it ain't about the money.
You're just singing it.
I'm for real; don't be blowing me up.
- It's easy to pull things back.
It's very hard to ramp things up.
I'd rather start with
something that's too big, and
pull it back into reality
than start with something
that's so easy that you
can't really get it up.
For example, don't set
your goals realistically,
set them entirely unrealistically.
Shoot for 80 and be
disappointed when you hit 70,
as opposed to shooting
for 20 and being ecstatic
when you hit 21.
We beat our goal!
Yeah, but it was a very low goal.
I think to be frustrated in
achieving something rather than
ecstatic and achieving less
is a better way to live.
Not to mention, you achieve more.
So, I'm a great believer
in the greater good.
Those things are so
big; they're ridiculous.
My goal, is a hundred-year
goal, is called world peace.
(laughs) So daunting,
but that's the idea.
If I fail, and I certainly
want to achieve it in my
lifetime, I'd like to think
that what I'll contribute
towards that ridiculous,
idealistic, nonsense goal
will be more than if I say,
"if I can just be happy
by myself, in my little house".
That's nice and all, but I
like the idea of contributing
to your neighbor as well.
- I don't want to be called an actor.
I don't want to be called a star.
I don't want to have a label.
I want to have a legacy.
I want to be known as someone who has
goals and achieves them.
Whatever they might be,
wherever they might be,
I want to be limitless.
I want to break stereotypes.
I want to go where no man
or woman has gone before.
It might be a scary path, it
might be a path that no one's
taken, but at least it'll be just mine.
I had the worst self-esteem
when I was a kid.
I was made fun of because
of the way I talked,
because of where I came from.
I was made fun of on every
level, and the only way you
can change that is setting
goals for yourself and saying
I will be the best version of me.
When I was 18, I started
doing movies, I gave myself
a year and a half, and I
said, "if I sense that I'm not
good at what I'm doing, and
I don't see something opening
up for me, I'm going
to go back to college".
I always had a plan B.
I still always have a plan B.
That's what I always tell young people.
Life doesn't end, it just keeps moving.
You have to put your blinkers
on and find what you do best,
and just keep moving.
- I want you to start
seeing something bigger.
I know you're all successful.
I'm talking about something
really big for your life.
In order to do that, you
have to answer this question,
what do you really want?
Now, I'm not talking
about something small.
I'm not talking about a little haiku.
I'm not talking about
renovating your kitchen.
I'm not talking about signing
on ten new customers this month.
I'm talking about what you really want.
Three years ago, I was a
lawyer and a business coach,
working with private
clients and big corporations
all over the country.
I came to a seminar, just like
this one, a big leadership
seminar and I went there with my husband.
We're both business
owners, and I went because
I wanted to be more successful.
I went because I wanted
to make even more money
than I already did.
I was sitting exactly where
you are, in fact, I was
sitting about 15 rows back,
right where that woman with
her hand, yeah you, she's
like, "hi", was sitting.
I was taking notes, and
I'm like, okay, I'm here
to make more money.
Then all of the sudden,
she walked on stage.
That is Martha Beck.
She writes a column for Oprah Winfrey.
She travels around the country speaking.
She's a best-selling author.
When she walked on stage, I
literally stopped listening.
Please keep listening
to me right now, okay.
It hit me.
I said, "I want to be doing that".
I'm ready for a bigger stage.
That's it.
What's so interesting about
when you answer that question,
is that you don't answer it
up here, you answer it here.
That's how you see something
bigger for yourself.
You guys are really cute
because everybody is like,
I don't see it, I don't see
anything for myself right now.
I'm just confused.
I thought I knew what I wanted.
Now Mel, I'm not really sure.
Right now, the economy is so bad.
It's so bad that even if
you're successful, I know
sometimes I feel embarrassed
talking about my success
around some of my friends because I know
that they're really struggling.
I get calls every day into
the radio show, people saying
I've got this great idea,
but I just don't know
if it's the right time.
You know what I say to them?
I say, yeah, you know, you're right.
The recession, it's huge.
You should wait.
Those dreams, yeah, put them on hold.
You should stay in that
job you can't stand
just a little bit longer.
You've got college bills to pay.
What you're doing, it's fine.
You're busy, right?
That guy you're dating,
he's good enough for you.
But, for the people in this room, bologna.
That's right, you know
exactly what you want,
and the only thing that you
need to do is to admit it.
This may sound weird because
I know most of you came
in here because you're like,
"I know what I want, I'm
here at Success to try to figure it out.
I'm talking about something bigger,
much bigger.
I'll admit to you what
it is that I'm up to.
The truth is, it's embarrassing
because when you lock
onto something way bigger
than where you're at,
it is down right embarrassing
to tell people because
you're not there yet.
At this rate, I've already
admitted to you that I stalked
Martha Beck, and that I
brought a haiku to the best
lit agent in the country,
so I've got nothing to lose
at this point.
This is what I want.
Well, not him, I'm married.
I want what he's got.
I want 600 radio stations.
I want two million listeners,
and I could certainly
deal with the $400 million salary.
In fact, if I got it, I'd
renovate everybody's kitchen.
The thing is though, that's
so interesting about this,
is that I didn't pick him.
I'm not looking to become a
cigar-smoking conservative
political guy that stirs the pot
and makes everybody all mad.
I'm the liberal lifestyle
gal that's trying
to help people out, but
what I want to do is I want
to use radio to entertain people and
help them achieve their dreams.
When I really think about
it, he's the one that's
in the front.
I want to not only reach what he is doing,
I want to surpass him.
Do you think I like it
when my friends come over
to my office in Boston at
my house, and they're like,
"what is that guy doing on your board?'.
No, it's embarrassing.
When you admit the big
thing that you're up to,
it's embarrassing.
I have 40 stations, he's got 600.
There's a big gap.
So, admitting where you want
to get to is embarrassing,
but you've got to do it.
- You see, the beautiful part
about goals, and understanding
it is goals are not to get.
You don't get set goals for acquisition.
You set goals to grow.
You set goals to reach
inside, stretch, and go where
you've never been.
You set goals to take you
to a place you've never gone
before, and you grow as a human being.
You don't accept it, you never go back.
- Now, I don't watch TV too much.
It's hard because most of the
time I watch a lot of ESPN,
but not anymore.
To be honest with you, try
to stay focused and set
little goals for myself every day.
Get a little bit better.
Learn one new thing and
improve in one way every day
when I step out here.
When you set all those
little goals and you keep
hitting them, then you're
constantly going to keep getting
better and not worry
about everything else.
just let that take care of itself.
Worry about what I can control.
First, let me say that I think
the goals, pretty much set
the tone for everything else.
I guess when you think about goal setting,
and when you really
allow your goals to start
becoming the lead to manage your steps
then your life path starts to become
guided, and not just
haphazard and by chance.
Your goals become the
predetermined address
that would serve as a
destination, an end result.
Now, with at least that,
you're able to make decisions
and map out a course,
step-by-step, if you will,
that will help get you there.
The really cool thing about
goal setting is that even
if you do not have all the
information beyond the address,
like, what streets,
where and when to turn,
with having the address, you
can always type in the GPS
coordinate and pretty much
take advantage of other
sensibilities that can help point you
in the right direction.
A lot of times, you don't
really need to have all
of the guess work predetermined
and already figured out.
Once you have the address,
you're that much closer
to being able to get
where you're trying to go.
As an athlete on stage,
that's kind of what I'm using
to help get me where I feel I need to be
to perform at maximum efficiency.
Goal setting is very, very important.
It's been very, very
critical in helping me get
from the beginning of my
career to where I am presently.
- You had a plan; the
remarkable thing to me was
at 22, 23 years old, that your plan
was completely laid out.
In reading your book, you
knew, I was going to take
this amount of money.
Your plan was to make
three El Mariachi movies.
- Yeah, the thing is, if
you want to get somewhere,
you've really got to set
some goals for yourself.
They won't ever happen
the way you planned, but
at least you ...
- Don't I know that.
- You'll step forward
in a positive direction
that may take you some
place better by accident.
- You just have to ... it's
not easy to see beyond where
you are, but you have to try
to see beyond where you are.
Try to set goals beyond where you are.
Think about ways that you can break out
and make a difference.
That's what I did.
I had some great people around
me, my family, teachers,
people that believed in
me and encouraged me.
Sent me off to an Ivy League school, and
I figured it out after that.
- But, why, some say, the moon?
Why choose this as our goal?
They may well ask, why
climb the highest mountain?
Why 35 years ago, fly the Atlantic?
Why does Rice play Texas?
We choose to go to the moon.
We choose to go to the moon
in this decade and do the
other things, not because they
are easy, but because they
are hard, because that goal
will serve to organize and
measure the best of our energies
and skills, because that
challenge is one that
we're willing to accept.
One we are unwilling to postpone,
and one we intend to win,
and the others too.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed it.
I'd love to know, what did
you take from this video
that you're going to immediately
apply somehow to your
life or to your business?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm really want to see
what you have to say.
I also want to give a
quick shout to Luis Lopez
from The Better Men Project.
Luis, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
I really appreciate the
support and I'm glad you
enjoyed your book.
- [Announcer] If you could
describe yourself with one word,
what would it be?
- So thank you guys for watching,
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe
in yourself and whatever
your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.